we weren't wrong about one thing and
that is aliens are real that is
Declassified by the Navy okay that's
real [ __ ] but how crazy is it how crazy
is it that yes the Pentagon released
videos of UFOs that could potentially be
real but how crazy is that that ninja
[ __ ] called it the day before it
happened no that was SpaceX what that
was SpaceX no but still you think it's a
big coincidence that ninja post this
video where he's like what did I just
see in the sky what was that dude and
all this day the Pentagon releases
videos yeah you think that's a
coincidence this big ninja fans in the
government and they saw that video they
were like ah we we don't want them to
totally look like a fool because we got
to protect our boy you gotta help our
boy out we can't let him just drown out
here on the internet looking like an
[ __ ]
not only is he you know adidas --is
favorite gamer he's also the government
the US government's favorite gamer and
so we got to protect our boy he's and
he's very exposed right now with this
video of him looking up in the sky going
to what did I just see and it's very
clearly satellite or something and so we
got to release these videos saying UFOs
are real yeah you know how like the FBI
has the most-wanted list
ninja is on favorite gamer list for the
Pentagon they have a top-10 list and
it's only him yes it's different
Tim ten times yeah yeah he's their
favorite gamer over here we have a
tribute to George Washington and these
are our favorite gamers hey Bob you see
that ninja highlight last night a super
clutch right and final so my god son oh
my god RPG oh what a play Oh sick what
an absolute play
[Laughter]
yeah go off king let's see outside
laying on our Bentley yeah on our bike
balcony and on the second floor with all
the lights off well reflect stargazing
we have no flex we're on the balcony on
the second floor I know a lot of you
guys know that we like to hang out on
the third and fourth floor this time
we're laying on the second floor just to
be a little bit you know closer to the
earth really gonna be so funny if you
just slipped in like so Jess and I were
just laying on the balcony of the 12th
floor of our home and we're stargazing
right before I'm sorry what for was that
Tyler what floor is that 12 the 12th of
the study and anyways so a star hold on
study for what it's it's right next to
the bowling alley Hut on the 12th don't
you it's not a very good study it's very
loud but a bowling alley in the but yeah
we need a view it notes it's it's right
above the top golf it's right about the
top golf in our home next to the bowling
alley which is actually a bowling alley
arcade we actually have arcade machines
next to that to two lanes so you can you
have something to do while you're yeah
we have bowling arcade games too never
done this in our entire relationship not
outside not in our house never she was
like this is gonna be cute I freaking I
don't get why he had to mention that and
by the way guys I've never stargazing in
my entire life I've never done this wack
[ __ ] before yeah I know it
I've never done this goofy ass [ __ ] in
my whole life never in my life have I
even thought to go outside look at some
[ __ ] stars [ __ ] about stars yeah
alright so here he goes cute freakin
[ __ ] you not what I thought was the
North Star which was the bright it was
the brightest I could see in the sky was
right next to the moon it starts
flashing it starts flashing and like 40
dots they all look like little mini
stars just start shooting out of it and
falling in a perfect straight line
across the sky try to get a video
couldn't record [ __ ] my phone wouldn't
pick it up
what what the hell is this what happened
well what the hell is this what does
happen my man is bugging out this frame
right hugging look at his eyes dude 42
seconds on this [ __ ] he's bugged the
[ __ ] out if you didn't know who he was
yeah you were what he if you'd if
someone sent you this tweet and you
didn't see the blue check or something
you would think he's like a meth addict
or something's just insane he's nobody's
like I'm sitting on the balcony with a
dude with Jess and I've never done this
before and there's a star shootout I
tried to get a picture and I just what
the hell did I just like he's pale too
blue that's sort of like faded blue hair
what did I just what did I just see it
was my man all right is he good yeah bro
well so that ended up being some SpaceX
satellites which I was thinking it is
kind of crazy how these companies can
just like an experiment in space and
like do launch satellites and these
crazy things and like not not talent
like the general public oh yeah the way
that everyone can know what's what's
going on so people like see these space
shuttle launches and some there and
stuff and they're like there has to be
probably like 20 people per launch that
think the world is ending
oh yeah legitimate Lee just inducing
tons of anxiety yeah did some guy
laughing about it at the console amen
you know someone's gonna end up on a
documentary because of this oh yeah dude
for sure farmer and his crop circle just
gets naked take me chip me take me away
from this it's dr. Phil take me away
from this place I'm so tired of my TV
show I need me alien daddies I need
something different put the chip in me
shame me shackle me make me feel small
everybody get the chip I'll need the
chip please
you